[Musik]
mein heutiger gast im dialog ist
hans-werner sind lange jahre präsident
des ifo-instituts immer noch
deutschlands bekanntester ökonomen
herzlich willkommen bei phoenix
pünktlich zu ihrem siebzigsten
geburtstag ist ihre autobiografie
erschienen und bei dem was sie uns über
ihren lebensweg erzählt ist mir einen
satz auf gefahren ich darf sie da mal
zitieren ich bin als politischer ökonom
angetreten die welt zu verbessern
werden sie dann nicht besser politiker
geworden
ja das ist sozusagen die
nebenbedingungen erstmal will ich bin
ich wissenschaftler ja und dann will ich
nicht einfach nur la polar machen und
andere wissenschaftler ansprechen
sondern meine erkenntnisse als volkswirt
halt auch so einbringen dass die welt
verbessert wird ja ich will dass also
von einer soliden basis ausmachen und
wenn ich politiker bin dann habe ich
eine andere rolle
das ist jetzt nicht so meine stärke ich
bin mehr von der wissenschaftlichen
seite her kommt analytisch unterwegs und
wenn sie jetzt zurück blick haben die
einfluss gehabt kamen die politiker auf
sie gehört ja nicht so direkt indirekt
schon sagen wir die riester rente
die hatte ich mit vorbereitet in einem
gutachten des beirats war im
wirtschaftsministerium und auch durch
entsprechende studien in den 90er jahren
und wir haben dann auch ein riester eine
assistentin eines lehrstuhls geschickt
der damit geholfen hat das
auszuformulieren dann auch die agenda
da gab es im mai 2002 eine studie die
ich selbst geleitet und wesentlich
geschrieben habe des ifo instituts über
die aktivierende sozialpolitik wir
wollten also mehr geld fürs fürs
mitmachen geben und umschichten ja so
dass es attraktiver wird auch am
arbeitsmarkt zu sein und das hat sehr
viel einfluss genommen
über den wissenschaftlichen beirat beim
wirtschaftsministerium über den
sachverständigenrat also über mehrere
kanäle dann auf die politik der
regierung stellt wir haben damals 2003
ein buch geschrieben ist deutsch
dann noch zu retten das liest sich quasi
wie die wissenschaftliche begründung für
die agenda 2010
ja so ist es interpretiert worden von
anderen es war auch so gemeint obwohl
ich ja nicht wusste was jetzt da genau
kommt aber ich wusste in welche richtung
es geht deutschland war weltmeister bei
der arbeitslosigkeit der
geringqualifizierten seit willy brandt
hatte die gesamtarbeitslosigkeit in
westdeutschland treppenförmig zugenommen
wir hatten ja 1970 überhaupt keine
arbeitslosen 150.000 nicht der rede wert
und dann kam also alle zehn jahre
800.000 dazu und es war ein verheerender
trend und dann weiß ich noch gab es
diese dot com blase im jahre 2000 und
dann dachte man jetzt wachsen wir nur
noch und europa kommt in eine
wundervolle phase hinein aber
pustekuchen
die blase platzte und dann gab's den
irak-krieg und so weiter stürzte alles
ab und dann hoffte man dass wenigstens
2002 wieder hochgeht manche prognosen
zeigt auch nach oben aber es kam der
aufschwung nicht zustande und die
regierung war damals ziemlich
verzweifelt da musste etwas passieren am
arbeitsmarkt musste mehr flexibilität
her
diese lohnskala musste gespreizt werden
wir brauchten einen niedriglohnsektor in
die falle schönes niedrige löhne zu
haben sondern weil es schönes jobs so
haben und dadurch das eben weniger geld
für das wegbleiben und mehr fürs
mitmachen gegeben wurde in der agenda
2010 ist der implizierte mindestlohn
gesenkt worden den arbeitnehmer
verlangen müssen von einem arbeitgeber
damit das überhaupt sich lohnt zu ihm zu
gehen ja und dadurch sind viele
geschäftsmodelle rentabel geworden und
das interessante ist es hat die
lautsprache die einkommensprüfung nicht
zugenommen sondern sie hat dramatisch
sogar abgenommen wie wir inzwischen
wissen weil ja doch viele leute
überhaupt in arbeit und brot gekommen
sind wir haben also mehr in gleichheit
und mehr jobs mehr inklusion in die
arbeitswelt bekommen es war eine ein
riesenerfolg
also hier sitzt ein energischer
verteidiger der agenda 2010
gerhard schröder hat zumindest indirekt
auf sie gehört wie
mit angela med ja die hat auch auf mich
gehört als sie dann damals zur wahl
anstand hat sie mich gebeten bei einer
kommission mitzuwirken die also ein
programm für die neue regierung
ausarbeiten sollte unter leitung von
herrn jungen der damals da auch mal
öffnen ist da gewesen ist und da muss
ich gar nicht viel tun die haben wir im
wesentlichen die punkte übernommen aus
dem letzten kapitel meines buches ist
deutschland noch zu retten
also das waren alles sehr sinnvolle
vorschläge aber was hat frau merkel dann
realisiert wenig eigentlich nichts kommt
gleich noch auf die neue bundesregierung
zu sprechen das thema mal kurz zurück
ich möchte noch ein bisschen bei ihrer
biografie bleiben für viele sind sie ja
so was wie die verkörperung des
marktradikalen in deutschland und wenn
man jetzt ihre biografie liest
hoppla sie kommen aus einer
sozialdemokratischen familie sie waren
selber sozialdemokrat was hat sie denn
an der sozialdemokratie fasziniert na ja
schon der gerechtigkeits gedanke das los
der kleinen leute zu denen wir ja selber
gehört nun meine eltern waren arm und
vater wurde in den krieg gezogen als
halbwüchsiger und konnte seine lehre
nicht zu ende machen war lastwagenfahrer
war ein taxifahrer also wir haben es
nicht leicht gemacht gehabt und aus
diesem bewusstsein heraus hatte ich
natürlich auch sehr viel sympathie und
habe ich nach wie vor für programme die
auf soziale gerechtigkeit abstellen mann
soll umverteilen wir brauchen einen
sozialstaat und wer mich in die ecke
stellt dass ich das gar nicht will also
der hat mich überhaupt nicht verstanden
ich habe das auch zeitlebens in meiner
lehre als hochschul professor im fach
finanzwissenschaft wo es also um die
rolle des staates geht immer offensiv
gelehrt und vertreten wie ein effizient
und gerecht organisierter staat
eigentlich
wieder aussehen muss ja das ist meine
frage und wo ist die grenzlinie zwischen
staat und privatem sektor
einiges kann der private sektor besser
anderes kann der staat besser und das
gilt es rational zu diskutieren leute
die diese rationale diskussion nicht
wollen neigen dazu einen dann in
irgendeiner ecke zu stellen das finde
ich immer fürchterlich statt sich mit
den argumenten auseinanderzusetzen
ein paar fotos aus der zeit von damals
hier haben wir sie bei den falken ist
dass das ist die oder war die
jugendorganisation der sozialdemokraten
und das hier ist eine demonstration
anlässlich der ermordung von martin
luther king da sehen wir sie ganz rechts
außen da können wir ein bisschen näher
rangehen
hier rechts außen sind sie im bild das
war 1968 würden sie sich selber als 68er
bezeichnung da haben sie sich damals als
68er gefühlt als teil der bewegung ja ja
sicherlich hatte gerade angefangen zu
studieren im herbst 1967 das war mein
praktisch im zweiten semester aber das
war ein bielefeld in meiner heimatstadt
ich habe in münster studiert und ich war
aber zum taxifahren bei meinem vater
dann häufig zu hause am wochenende und
musste geld verdienen
und da fand dann diese demonstration
statt die ist auch von den falken
organisiert worden und da habe ich
mitgemacht hier trage dieses schild das
sieht man jetzt nicht oben ist martin
luther king drüber auf diesem selben
schild das haben sie jetzt irgendwie
abgeschnitten darum ging es nicht wir
wollten also demonstrieren gegen diese
ungerechtigkeit die den schwarzen in
amerika angetan
also damals sozialdemokrat fühlen sie
sich denn immer noch als sozialdemokrat
oder haben sie da ihre einstellungen
inzwischen geändert nein eigentlich in
gewisser weise immer noch also ich will
mich auch nicht parteipolitisch bin ich
habe also damals gemerkt dass die nähe
zu parteipolitischen gruppierungen ich
war danach im sozialdemokratischen
hochschul bund
doch verpflichtet dann das lied dieser
gruppe zu singen und das hat mir
überhaupt nicht gefallen also ich bin
schon damals er der meinung gewesen die
wissenschaft ist das richtige und man
muss also unabhängig drüber nachdenken
aber die präferenzen dass wir eine
gerechte gesellschaft haben
die haben sich nicht verändert ich habe
nur natürlich durch das studium der
volkswirtschaftslehre er erkannt was die
möglichen wege sind und das so naive
umverteilungs vorstellung dass man es
einfach einfach den einen das wegnimmt
und den anderen das gibt so leicht nicht
zum ziel führen sondern man muss das
geschickt da machen man muss schon
umverteilen aber man muss aufpassen dass
bei der umverteilung nicht die anreize
sich in den arbeitsprozess zu
integrieren
ein kleiner werden sondern man muss mehr
das geld zum mitmachen geben als zum weg
bleiben also dieser alte sozialstaat der
auf lohnersatzleistungen basiert man
kriegt das staatliche geld wenn man
nicht arbeitet und wer man arbeitet dann
hört das starken dieser geldfluss auf
das habe ich immer für vollkommen falsch
gefunden ich meine idealvorstellung ist
dass jobs für alle gibt dass die löhne
dann gegebenenfalls so niedrig sind dass
eben geschäftsmodell wir zustande kommen
aber dass die löhne nicht gleich den
einkommen sind sondern dass zusätzlich
der staat ein weiteres einkommen gibt
als lohnzuschuss oder das in der summe
aus einem niedrigen beschäftigung
schaffenden lohn und diesem zuschuss ein
akzeptables gesamteinkommen wünscht ich
versuche das zu verstehen also der
niedriglohnsektor ist nicht schlecht
sondern im gegenteil anzustreben damit
die menschen arbeit haben und der staat
soll das dann ausgleich der staat soll
es dann ausgleichen ja weil wir waren
sagt die löhne müssen so hoch sein dass
waren von den löhnen arbeiten kann das
fordern ja viele jeder muss von seiner
hände arbeit leben können dass eine
formel forderung die lässt sich nur in
der marktwirtschaft nicht realisieren
weil man die unternehmer ja nicht
zwingen kann leute einzustellen
die zu teuer sind so dass als das der
rentable geschäftsmodelle entstehen man
muss also den lohn in seiner als
kostenfaktor für die unternehmen trennen
von dem einkommen welches den
lebensstandard sichert wenn man beides
versuch mit einer variablen hinzukriegen
nur mit dem lohn dann geht es schief das
kann gar nicht funktionieren ist die
große leistung von schröder
wir haben heute millionen von leuten die
von leuten die nicht mehr von ihrem lohn
alleine leben müssen sondern zusätzlich
noch was vom staat dazu kriegen und in
der summe entsteht dann ein einkommen
das jedenfalls höher ist als das was sie
früher hatten und im alten system gehabt
hätten also eine wirkliche verbesserung
davon abgesehen werden die menschen in
den arbeitsprozess integriert sie lernen
dort kollegen kennen sie sind teil einer
recht gesunden lebens weltstadt dass sie
zu hause bleiben weil es keine jobs gibt
und dann zwangsläufig nur auf die stütze
angewiesen sind und die kinder in einem
milieu erziehen wo die auch nur lernen
wie man zum sozialamt geht ich habe
finde das ganz ganz schrecklich
man tut den menschen und ihren kindern
einen tort an wenn man das system so
aufsetzt
ihre autobiografie auf der suche nach
der wahrheit ist eine wirklich
interessante mischung zwischen
beschreibung ihres lebenswegs und
stellungnahmen zu aktuellen politischen
problem wollen wir hier in der sendung
genau so halten wir sprechen daher noch
noch weiter übrigen ihren lebensweg aber
schauen wir mal aufs aktuelle wir haben
die neue regierung was halten sie denn
von dem was die koalition aus union und
spd machen werden ja die wollen ganz
viel geld ausgeben und dass der
koalitionsvertrag liest sich ja fast wie
ein wunschzettel für weihnachten jeder
kriegt so ein bisschen was und finde ich
eigentlich nicht so richtig denn die
steuereinnahmen sprudeln derzeit wegen
der guten konjunktur und sie sprudeln
sogar überproportional wir haben ja ein
progressives steuersystem das heißt wer
mehr einkommen hat zahlt auch in höheren
prozentsatz ja das muss auch so sein
aber das problem ist wenn jetzt die
wirtschaft wächst ja dann wachsen die
staatlichen steuereinnahmen schneller
als die einkommen die überhaupt
erwirtschaftet werden der staat ist also
mit einem immer größeren prozentsatz am
volkseinkommen dabei und
das geld sollte er den leuten
zurückgeben
manchmal gibt ja auch ein bisschen was
zurück und tut an der st besonders
großzügig davon kann gar nicht die rede
sondern wir müssen eigentlich ein system
haben wo der progression tarif wie man
sagt auf räder gestellt wird wurde ja um
ja automatisch angepasst wird so dass
tatsächlich die staatlichen
steuereinnahmen prozentual nicht mehr
schneller wachsen als die privaten
einkommen
ich verstehe was sie sagen ich würde sie
trotzdem gern mit mit dem gegenargument
konfrontieren sind wir nicht jetzt in
der phase der hochkonjunktur in einer
phase wurde start sehr viel geld hat
genau an der richtigen stelle wo der
staat dafür sorgen muss dass auch die
kleinen leute was vom aufschwung haben
durch kindergeld durch eine grundrente
durch eine garantie des rentenniveaus
natürlich müssen alle partizipieren
anteilig das ist richtig dass die dürfen
ja nicht abgehängt werden aber es ist ja
nicht richtig in einem aufschwung
die zusätzlichen steuereinnahmen zu
verausgaben sondern im aufschwung müsste
der staat schulden tilgen um im
abschwung das gegenteil zu tun um dann
möglicherweise schulden zu machen um mit
dem geborgten geld die wirtschaft wieder
auf trab zu bringen also das ist die
standard empfehlung der volkswirtschaft
gut aber wenn sie jetzt in dieser phase
sagen wir ersten zahlen schulden zurück
zweitens wir senken die steuern dann
frage ich drittens was haben dann die
kleinen leute davon wo wird ihnen
geholfen
ja die steuern steigen ja trotzdem die
steuereinnahmen es ist ja was ist ja
mehr da und man kann alle
sozialleistungen proportional zur
wirtschaftsleistung erhöhen es geht
darum dass nicht überproportional zu
erhöhen sondern alles muss sich in
gleichmäßiger proportion vergrößern das
ist genau der punkt und noch mal die
progressivität des steuersystems sorgt
dafür dass der staat überproportional
dabei ist er kriegt mehr als die
privaten
und das ist nicht richtig denn letztlich
müssen die menschen selber entscheiden
wie sie ihre einkommen verwenden wollen
da darf nicht der staat immer mehr für
sich an immer größeren prozentsatz
absorbieren und dann das füllhorn
ausschütten
dann kommen wir in ein schiefes
fahrwasser denken sie nur wie es den
franzosen gegangen ist die haben das ja
gemacht über jahrzehnte hinweg und haben
hohe staatsquote von 50 56 prozent so
ziemlich die größte aller entwickelten
länder und das land nicht am boden so
kann es nicht sein herrliche überleitung
auf europa ganz zentraler bestandteil im
koalitionsvertrag ist dass sich die
regierung vorgenommen hat wir wollen
europa stärken
dann gibt es noch keine so klare
vorstellungen was die regierung
eigentlich will aber es gibt klare
vorstellungen des französischen
präsidenten makro der will europa
stärken indem man die eurozone stärkt
euro-finanzminister europäische banken
union sollten wir damit machen
ja sicher sie dann sollten wir europa
stärken ich bestreite nur dass das was
man will europa stark das wird europa
schwächen er will eine umverteilung
union
er will die haftung vergemeinschaften
über verschiedene mechanismen wir sollen
die einlagen in die bei den banken die
die leute haben in ganz europa gemeinsam
absichern in höhe von 100000 euro pro
konto frage ist nur wo sind wir denn das
durchschnittsvermögen also das median
vermögen eines deutschen eines mittleren
haushalts liegt bei 50 60.000 euro da
sollen wir also in griechenland und co
jedes konto mit 100000 euro absichern
das sind doch utopische vorstellungen
sie sind auch sehr gefährlich weil sie
zur folge haben dass zombie-banken
marode banken die herum zocken jetzt
ohne weiteres kundengelder bekommen denn
die kunden ist ja keine angst mehr haben
diesen banken ihr geld zu geben das ist
ja gemeinschaftlich abgesichert und dann
wird das riskant investiert wir haben
dasselbe in amerika gehabt und das
mündete in der großen savings and loan
krise anfang der achtzigerjahre der sind
hunderte von banken anschließen
untergegangen die hatten auch unter dem
schutz der gemeinschaftlichen haftung
für die konnten sich beliebig
kundengelder besorgt und haben die sehr
riskant angelegt wenn das gut gegangen
wäre hätten sie die gewinne
ausgeschüttet an ihre dividenden
und es ist etwas schief gegangen und
weil es schiefgehen haben sich die
dividenden die aktionäre aus dem staube
gemacht und der staat musste mit 150
milliarden dollar hier einspringen das
wird im moment möglicherweise wiederholt
in europa nicht so kann ich eine banken
union nur verstehen das kann nicht
sinnvoll sein okay jetzt will ich mal
vom vom detail der banken union absehen
und und auf das große ganze sehen also
das aus deutscher sicht ist ja für viele
das schreckgespenst wir geraten hinein
in eine transfer-union also der reiche
norden das reiche deutschland muss für
den armen süden zahlen diejenigen die
das verteidigen die sagen das wird
zwangsläufig so kommen wenn wir an
einheit die es gemeinsam das europa
wollen dann wird das reiche deutschland
für den armen süden bezahlen müssen
sonst bricht europa auseinander und sind
das können wir gar nicht soviel geld
gibt zu behaupten ich wir konnten das
kleine griechenland mit viel geld retten
aber können wir jetzt italien retten
wenn die wenn die italiener jetzt kommen
so können wir die spanier mit retten mit
ihren 900 milliarden außen schulden
gegenüber dem ausland netto das sind ja
alles summen da müssen die länder selber
sich darum kümmern wir können nicht die
schulden vergemeinschaften weil ja auch
dann gefahren drohen weil wenn man die
schulden vergemeinschaftet dann drückt
man künstlich die zinsen zu denen sich
diese überschuldeten länder verschulden
können und sie verschulden sich immer
weiter wir haben das ähnlich gesehen
eigentlich in den usa in den ersten
jahrzehnten die haben den gleichen
fehler gemacht den wir jetzt in europa
wiederholen
alexander hamilton der erste
finanzminister der usa hat 1791 die
schulden der einzelstaaten zu
bundesschulden gemacht wie also nutzer
weise sozialisiert und dann gab es noch
eine zweite sozialisierung runde und
dann dachten die stadt leiste prima wenn
man schulden macht hat man das geld man
kann straßen brücken kanäle bauen
die wirtschaft kommt auf aufschwung und
den schuldendienst näher der den
schieben wir nach washington damit haben
wir nichts zu tun
und das ließ sich gut an die ersten
jahrzehnte schienen das und eine
wunderschöne entwicklung zu sein das
geld war ja daher nur dann waren sie
alle so verschuldet und der bund konnte
auch nicht mehr tragen dass das ganze
system platz
neun von 29 staaten und territorien sind
in der zeit von 1837 bis 42
pleitegegangen und nichts als hass und
streit war entstanden aus dieser
schulden union
und dann haben die amerikaner eine
schwierige phase gehabt 19 jahre später
gab es den sezessionskrieg der eben
nicht nur wegen der sklaven frage
entstanden ist sondern auch wegen dieser
ungelösten schuldenfrage und erst als
der sezessionskrieg vorbei war kam
amerikaner in ruhigeres fahrwasser aber
in eines wo es keine schulden
sozialisierung mehr gibt kalifornien ist
pleite minnesota ist bleibt glauben sie
die anderen staaten würden helfen
glauben sie washington würde helfen
keiner hilft und weil das so ist geben
die kreditgeber diesen ländern auch
keinen neuen kredit die müssen sich also
bescheiden und müssen selber sehen wie
sie mit ihren gläubigern sag ich
versuche jetzt mal aus der sicht der
europäischen zentralbank zu
argumentieren die ezb sagt wir haben es
doch gezeigt durch unsere entschlossene
politik haben wir gezeigt dass man
europa stabilisieren kann dass man dafür
sorgen kann dass die konjunktur in
europa ins laufen kommt und wir haben
die euro krise zumindest gezähmt wenn
nicht überwunden ja die konjunktur haben
so sicher angeschoben das sie haben in
dem sie die gemeinschaftliche haftung
eingeführt haben insbesondere im jahr
2012 mit dem rotary tags von mario
draghi oder gesagt hat leute kauft ruhig
spanische papiere keine rolle wenn die
breite gehen ich kaufe ihr euch vorher
ab ja eher trap trat kein risiko damit
hat er die zinsen zu denen die spanier
sich verschulden konnten gedrückt die
spreads sagt man ja und die folge ist
dass sich spanien munter verschuldet hat
und diese verschuldung macht einen
binnenwirtschaftlichen boom die gehälter
im staat können wieder steigen die
renten können steigen
die leute können ins restaurant gehen
alles was da dran hängt am start geht
wird wird wirt künstlich belebt nur es
hilft ja nicht der wettbewerbsfähigkeit
des landes krise zurück kommt ja
sicherheit die ist ja noch latent
vorhanden
das was mario trage ich auch gemacht hat
er hat eben sukzessive die zinsen
gesenkt die banken und die
kapitalanleger verlieren also insofern
erträge umgekehrt führt das aber zu
einer portfolio umschichtung hin zu
aktien hin zu immobilien und so weiter
die werte steigen und der wertzuwachs
hier hat den verlust an zinseinnahmen
kompensiert das ist aber ein temporäres
phänomen
die zinsen sind jetzt bei null weiter
kann hat nicht der wertzuwachs hört auf
und jetzt haben die banken ein
riesenproblem wir stehen also am beginn
einer ganz ganz schwierigen phase wo die
banken europas
die nachteile dieser politik spüren
werden und die italiener sind an der
spitze dieses dieser gefährlichen
entwicklung wohl so sehr viele
forderungen der banken schon
abzuschreiben sind und das bankensystem
am rande der pleite
mit dieser eher negativen prognose mache
ich an der stelle man ein stricher b6
kommen noch mal auf ihre biographie
zurück sie haben sie am anfang gesagt
sie kommen aus sehr bescheidenen
verhältnissen vater lkw-fahrer haben sie
ja schon gesagt sie sind dann als
einziger aus ihrer grundschuld klasse
aufs gymnasium gekommen dann studium
professor haben sie mal überlegt wie
oder warum eben das gelungen ist ja das
weiß ich auch nicht also an meinen
eltern lag das bestimmt nicht die werden
nie auf die idee gekommen dass der junge
aufs gymnasium gehen soll das hatte der
lehrer empfohlen da musste man ja noch
name damals eine aufnahmeprüfung machen
und da muss sogar geld bezahlt werden
aber meine eltern ich bin meinen eltern
sehr dankbar dass sie das akzeptiert
haben als der lehrer vorgeschlagen hat
und dann konnte ich also tatsächlich
aufs gymnasium gehen
ich habe auch immer mitgearbeitet also
ich habe versucht zurück zugeben dass
ich konnte so lange ich zu hause war und
ja gut dann kamen die dinge plötzlich
war ich dann im studium und am ende des
studiums verbot mir ein professor an bei
ihm assistenz zu werden dann habe ich
probiert ich wusste ja nicht dass sie
formulieren würde also das ergab sich so
und dann gewann ich spaß an der sache
sehr viel spaß an dieser wissenschaft
und merkte dass mir das leicht viel und
habe also sehr viel publiziert und war
dann plötzlich in diesem fahrwasser drin
und dann gab eins das andere
stimmt der eindruck dass so ein aufstieg
wie er ihnen gelungen ist dass das heute
schwerer oder gar fast unmöglich ist
nein also der anteil der alterskohorte
der überhaupt aufs gymnasium geht war ja
damals nur fünf prozent heute sind wir
ja fast beim zehnfachen insofern ist es
leichter aber ich weiß nicht ob die
lehrer noch so gut sind ehrlich gesagt
früher war der lehrerberuf werden ganz
hoch stehender beruf ja wenn jemand
studienrat wohl dann hat er es geschafft
im leben weiß nicht ob der nimbus des
studienrats noch so hohes wir haben
tolle lehrer gehabt und für einen
sozialen aufstieg brauchen sie
erstklassige lehrer die eben dinge
kompensieren die vom elternhaus nicht
kommen und ich bin in den genuss dieser
großartigen lehrer gekommen da am
helmholtz-gymnasium in bielefeld muss
ich immer noch daran denken und ich bin
ihm ewig dankbar
wir haben noch ein paar weitere fotos
vorbereitet hier sehen wir sie mit ihrer
ehefrau gerlinde seit 46 jahren sind sie
verheiratet
im studio haben wir geheiratet ja ja ja
wann sie ihre frau ist volkswirtin wie
sie das erste buch das erste größere
buch haben sie noch gemeinsam
herausgebracht gingen damals um die
deutsche wiedervereinigung
drei kinder haben sie gemeinsam das hier
ist dass der mittlere ja also sie haben
zwei söhne eine tochter
hier sehen wir die gesamte familie
er ist einer der kinder in die
fußstapfen des vaters getreten volkswirt
geworden nein also die hatte nie das
gefühl zwei volks würde in der familie
reichen
ich habe mal was anderes ihre frau hat
dann zugunsten der kinder ihre karriere
aufgegeben wissen sie ob sie das bereut
hat sie sagt sie hat es nicht bereut
sondern sie fand das richtig warum
naja das ist letztlich so habilitieren
können nicht 2 und kann man auch nicht
mit 50 prozent der zeit ist so eine
ziemlich hohe hürde
da müssen sie alles rein setzen damit
sie diese hürde überspringen und sie hat
gemeint dass es doch besser ist sie
kümmert sich jetzt stärker um die kinder
und ich konnte meinen beruflichen weg
machen dafür bin ich sehr dankbar ohne
meine frau hätte das nicht gelingen
können
inzwischen haben sich die zeiten
geändert erstes mal verbesserte
kinderbetreuung und natürlich auch ein
verändertes denken über die
arbeitsteilung in der familie
glauben sie dass die familie sehen sich
heute anders entscheiden würde oder auch
anders entscheiden könnte oder gilt da
in den wissenschaftsbetrieb immer noch
dasselbe was sie gerade gesagt haben das
schafft man nicht wenn man familie und
karriere und daher als bringt immer noch
also es gibt natürlich rühmliche
ausnahmen wo das dann trotzdem geht aber
in der regel muss man so bauern um die
habilitation zu schaffen und dann
professor zu werden auch im wettbewerb
dass das mit reduzierter kraft nicht
geht ja die meisten betreiben dann immer
noch eine irgendeine form von
arbeitsteilung hier
und was ist denn dagegen zu sagen wenn
man eine arbeitsteilung alles muss ja
jede familie für sich entscheiden wie
sie das machen will ich weiß dass das
jeder alles gleich macht sehe ich
überhaupt nicht wo der sinn sein soll
als volks wer das ganze wirtschaftsleben
besteht ja auch darin dass man eine
arbeitsteilung hat und wendet das dem
glück der familie zuträglich ist diesen
weg zu wählen
der ja zugegeben dann eher ein
traditioneller weg ist wieso kann man
sagen dass menschen sich falsch
entschieden haben das so gemacht haben
meine frau ist glücklich mit dem weg ich
bin es auch
dann beginne auch muss man im
zweifelsfall in kauf nehmen dass die
situation so wie sie ist bei den
volkswirten da ist glaube ich kommt auf
einen weiblichen professor für
volkswirtschaft ich weiß nicht wie viele
fünf oder zehn männliche das müsste man
dann hinnehmen essent nein das kann ja
auch mal umgekehrt sein dass der mann
die rolle übernimmt zu hause nicht wer
das dann ist es ist dann unklar
wir haben auch zunehmend weibliche
professorin heute gilt sogar so also
ohne jemandem zu nahe zu treten
für frauen ist es in gewisser weise dann
leichter die akademische karriere zu
machen weil ihnen die die jobs ja
nachgeworfen jeder will unbedingt eine
frau um die quoten einzuhalten und so
weiter ein mann muss heute in der
wissenschaft er besser qualifiziert
seien als die frau damit er die gleichen
chancen hat finden sie das falsch dass
das heißt ja also quotensystem finde ich
nicht richtig
das wird ja zu einer umgekehrten
diskriminierung
man sollte schon die nehmen die am
besten sind
das war der dialog heute mit professor
hans werner sinn herzlichen dank dass
sie zeit für uns hatten
herzlichen dank an sie für ihr interesse
[Musik]
[Applaus]